chrissy we have to start with this is us
and the episode that left people feeling
i don't know they don't know
what they feel no i just need to know if
movie quotes or impressions are allowed
that's all
yes this is the last time i'm doing this
so go crazy brother
beautiful okay thank you
it's really great oh come on jeez kill a
guy for trying to deliver a perfect
wedding speech
hey listen uh you're okay if i do some
british jokes at your expense right
hey if you can't take the piss out for
your future brother-in-law who can you
take the pistol off
at what point did you know toby was not
your forever person
oh boy uh you mean as far as dan and the
story line yeah
he's gonna say he will always chris will
always be um
you know there was always sort of talks
about it there's always sort of
who's who's the couple that's not going
to potentially make it and
since the like people knew kind of kind
of yeah
yeah yeah i mean they've really
orchestrated the seasons because they
knew it was going to be six and they
sort of
had the bones for quite some time and
then it was sort of just all the
particulars
and so i had a conversation over zoom um
right before we're starting the season
about the particulars
and i remember just like sobbing on the
on the zoom with dan and he was like
he's like chrissy i'm like i know dan
you know me i'm just
i can't help it uh so we've known for
quite some time though
that is devastating to my little fan
heart
inside how do you think i feel every day
i look at one christian the other crit
yeah i get it what a mislead i know like
i know
is there a chance for reconciliation
maybe why not next season why not like
this is what's so cool is that
nothing is well a linear but nothing you
know nothing is sort of out of the
question
which i find to be really fascinating
but
who knows we're not ready
we're still not ready i know how
emotional
i know you're you guys know the story
ahead of time
how emotional is it going to be for you
to say goodbye to kate
even thinking about it even when we did
our uh event last night the drive-in at
the rose bowl
just seeing sort of um
our conversations talking about the last
season was like very emotional i was
like oh
it's not gonna be good it's not gonna be
easy for me like i'm already like the
emotions are always right here with me
and so yeah it's going to be really uh
difficult i'm just gonna try to relish
in in the moment and just stay as
present as possible
uh and not future trip until like not
having
kate but i mean of course the show will
live on forever and we can always
re-watch it but
yeah i don't i don't think i'm ready uh
well i know i'm not ready
yeah yeah it's hard it's nobody's ready
i mean we've we've all connected as an
audience to this show and to these
characters in such a way that it's like
you guys are family
so like when things don't work out the
way we want them to work out i know
ah it's gutting but that's life what
you've mentioned that like you guys have
shot some of the series
finale we've banked uh some footage for
the
series what can you tease anything are
you kidding
i want to keep my job for the next
season uh well you know
i think there'll be some really
beautiful closure
and also i think we'll get to learn a
little bit about
um miguel and
you know john bless his heart miguel
gets such a bad rap
and he's really the one that's come to
the rescue uh for the pearsons and
in such a beautiful way and sort of in
the shadow
you know and he's always always will be
in the shadow of jack of course
but he had a promise to him and so i'm
i'm looking forward to seeing that
and also
the way that rebecca is handling her
diagnosis
and of course all the things that are
continuing to change
within uh kate and toby's relationship
and what does it mean about
co-parenting and and all the things and
so
that's what's hard right because it's
five years into the future so
everybody's created this narrative of
what's gonna happen or they're putting
in their own
uh their own theory so yeah we're gonna
there's so much to uncover and also
learn in a season
when you've been getting to know all
these characters for
for five seasons so it'll be of course
interesting it's gonna be emotional
emotionally packed for sure let's fast
forward
so season finale happens we maybe have
some
some closure with kate the rest of the
cast moving
forward is there an opportunity in your
mind in your heart to explore
kate as a spin-off or another character
i mean that would be so cute it would be
amazing that would be wonderful
i don't know if that is possible or if
that's something that's in anybody's
mind anything is possible i i don't know
if maybe it would be a
sort of a family that was
i think it might be cool spinoff to have
a family that was
somehow affiliated with the family but
with the pearsons but not necessarily
directly
um related i don't know and maybe that
we could sort of come in and out
of as they sort of came in and out of
our story that we could come in out of
their story
that would be kind of cool to have
another family but um
i think you have to i mean you have to
have some sort of spin off either that
or you guys are going to have to hire
counselors for all the fans that are not
okay i know we've been the therapy and
now we've got to hire some therapy i
think
i know you're right talk to me a little
bit about so
the show debuted in the fall this season
will air mid-season so
fans will be able to watch it all
they're going to wait a little longer
but
be able to watch it all in order yes how
awesome and important is that
i think thank you for everybody who's
hung
hung on because this year for so many
reasons
uh was incredibly difficult but also to
have a show that you're like i need this
and to sort of have it very uh here and
there
you know because of everything that's
going on it's sort of like
thank you for sticking with us here's a
whole season in its entirety
um you know because it's hard when
you're so invested and then you're like
i start stop so i think it's a really
nice
while it's mid-season it's still really
nice to have all the episodes together
yeah yeah i agree i mean it's you always
we used to say like oh it's so fun to
wait week to week and only see a thing
but now we're so
hungry to see these characters lives
play out yeah it's it's amazing
yeah um your tv brother yes your tv
brother just got married and
congratulations to him
is he happy are they enjoying themselves
partying he is so happy
yeah um there's such joy and light in
his eyes i'm so excited for
for and forget all the congratulations
from the e.t family oh yeah yeah
your other co-star have you met baby gus
yet of course oh yeah
yes mandy brought him to set a couple
weeks ago he's
a little muffin baby he is so cute
i think he's like already singing i
guess it's what's supposed to happen
when taylor goldsmith and mandy moore
are your parents right um no pressure
gus um
yeah he's just a little little love he's
like it just comes naturally yeah
yeah i think so